جنوبيون من القرى الحدوديه اجبرتهم
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على ترك ارضهم
بعدما اصبحوا عرضه للقصف والغارات وجهتهم
الاقرب مدينه صور على الساحل
الجنوبي الى هنا نزحت الحاجه سهام عائلتها
من بلده بيت ليف مراره النزوح وصعوبته كما
تقول ارحم من العيش تحت القصف الاسرائيلي
الذي ارعب
احفادها نحن عندنا بيوت عننا رازق عننا
زيتون كله تركن وظهرنا نا 70 نهار ظهرين
ما بدي احاربه وارجع على بيتي لو كان مهدم
بتمنى اعمل خيمه واقعد
ببيتي ما تتمناه سهام يعاكسه الميدان فمع
اشتداد القصف الاسرائيلي واتساع رقعته
جغرافيا تزايدت اعداد النازحين الالاف
هجروا قراهم ونزح الى بلدات بعيده عن
الحدود وصول الى العاصمه ومناطق اخرى
اعداد تضاعفت معها التحديات في ظل
الامكانيات المحدوده للسلطات اللبنانيه
البرد عم بزيد كثير عليهم في ناس كثير ماد
عم تلاقي لا غرف ولا اماكن للايجار لحتى
تقعد فيها او انه بيوت تستضيفها في بعض
البلديات بلغتنا انه ماش فيها تستقبل
نازحين الصفرات لا تكاد تهدا في هذا
المركز مهمات الاخلاء والانقاذ متواصله
ليل نهار فالاستخدام
دنيين وبيوتهم بات شبه يوميه نحن اليوم
بحرب حرب مع دو اسرائيلي التحديات انه نحن
عم نطلع على المهمات على الضيع ما بنعرف
شو مخبيلنا ما بنعرف ايمت بينزل قصف علينا
ما بنعرف
ايمتى بنضرب بلغ القصف الاسرائيلي مرات
عده محيطه هذه المدينه وبلدات في عمق
محافظه جنوب لبنان التي لا جا اليها
النازحون لكنها رغم ذلك ما زالت تشكل
مناطق امنه نسبيا مقارنه ببلدات الشريط
الحدودي حيث حل الدمار وغابت او تكاد كل
مظاهر
الحياه لم تبقي المقاتلات والمسيرات
الاسرائيليه اي بقعه امنه هنا عند الخط
الامامي من الحدود منازل مدمره واراض
محروقه ومدارس ومستشفيات جوره ويخشى ابناء
هذه القرى ان لا تعود حياتهم قريبا الى ما
كانت عليه وهم الذين اختبروا وط الاحتلال
واستهدافه المتكرره للمدنيين طيله عقود
كترين حنا الجزيره جنوبيه لبنان